liberals voted for lawlessness and
unfortunately they're paying the price
police arresting one of the suspects
behind that Viral La flash mob robbery
but get this she was let loose from jail
on similar robbery charges just one day
before the Brazen Heist and you can
thank radical D.A George gascon's
cashless bail policy for that one
Chicago also voted for Liberal
lawlessness a TV news crew they just got
robbed at gunpoint while literally
reporting on robberies there's no
footage of it because the crook stole
the damn camera and then there's the
capital of America's crime crisis the
San Francisco Bay Area one of the
liberal leaders there becoming a victim
of his own neighborhood while the
council member was speaking with
shopkeepers about Public Safety he got
robbed of his wallet and keys he wasn't
shocked he even joked about it quote the
thing is they're not going to get much
from it I'm on a politician's budget
Janine we've been covering this more and
more
it's it's like City Council Members TV
news crews the crime is rising from the
bottom up and no one knows when it's
going to stop well you know when gascon
was up for a recall it failed okay
Californians voted for proposition 47.
now I want to take you down a little
history for a second uh Kamala Harris
was the Attorney General at the time of
proposition 47. she called it the safe
neighborhood and schools act what it did
is it released felonies to misdemeanors
uh as it related to grand larceny and if
you were a felon already in jail you
could be re-sentenced to a misdemeanor
okay so then they passed 57 proposition
where they called it public safety
Californians voted for that where they
get you out of jail sooner for a
non-violent felony was it not violent
felony rape of an unconscious woman uh
hostage taking human trafficking hostage
taking is non-violent it's non-violent
so what I'm saying is in California I
mean you've got to dig below the first
layer and find out what they're trying
to do to you on the first day in office
gascon said I am going to end cash bail
bail is a constitutional right I mean
it's the Eighth Amendment to the
Constitution and yet he is the D.A
literally put an end to it so here's
what we've got to do in California
everyone's suffering if you live near
the water your boat's getting robbed if
you if you're at a store your store is
getting and we're all paying for it
through insurance through increased
retail uh cost as well as paying for
security in the stores if you literally
if you end up robbing a store and you'll
get bail the same day so that you can
then hit another store so if you're out
on bail for uh theft of one store
they've got to change the law it should
be a quick fix that you can't be out on
bail for two separate felonies that
can't who's against that right because
we're allowing a whole generation to
literally Rob Us blind and turn us into
a third world country Pierce how do you
see it I think it's time to go Singapore
ah I say as a California resident I have
a home there it is completely out of
control this kind of impunity the Brazen
impunity of these flash mob robbers now
someone called it organized retail crime
I think it's a very good phrase for what
you're seeing they are completely Brazen
and acting with such impunity because
they think there is zero chance of being
properly held accountable for what
they're doing and even if they are
caught they'll be let back out and they
can do it all over again as quite a few
of this number were not just that one
person in Singapore a person found
guilty of robbery of this nature will
get a jail term of two to ten years oh
and they get caned at least six times I
thought you were going to say they get
their hair they don't get the hand cut
off for that but if the robberies
committed between 7 pm and 7 A.M in
other words at night time the offender
will get a jail term of three to
fourteen years and 12 strokes and if you
hurt someone in the process of your
robbery in Singapore you get five to
twenty years along with 12 strokes and
people will be looking at this going we
couldn't possibly do that America well
why are you letting this happen actually
I think a lot of people watching to go
Singapore sounds like they've got this
about right because guess what the
robbery rate in Singapore is 1.3 cases
per 100 000 population Nobody Does this
in Singapore you know why
and they get sent to jail for years
remember when that American kid did it
in Singapore and he was going to get
caned and everybody flipped down but he
was vandalizing he was breaking and
there was more outrage from a lot of
people in America about what happened to
him the Singapore law than what you see
we just don't let other countries
no we won't that's the problem that is
the problem I also think this adds into
the urban Doom Loop problem so there's a
commercial real estate problem in mid
and large cities in America and this is
coming to your wallet I think because
they're going to ask for a bailout
because the people haven't come back
since covid and that means not just to
the workplace but also to theater to
events and so now all those leases are
going to be in trouble there's a huge
credit problem and they're going to have
to come in and ask Congress to help them
out which means that all of you are
going to have to help them out but one
of the main reasons people don't want to
come into the City and let's not even
talk about Chicago it's about Denver
like nobody wants to go downtown because
they had revitalized it it was fabulous
it was wonderful and now they even had
an event where on they would close off
the streets to traffic so that everybody
could go down and like enjoy themselves
but they did it last year all these
businesses lost money why because nobody
wants to go because you're stepping over
homeless people and crawling through
needles and you're afraid that you're
going to get robbed and Denver's not the
only one like it's happening all over so
be prepared the urban Doom Loop is
coming street fairs anyway you do I hate
them so here's the problem this is what
these people voted for I mean it's not
like it was it hit him by mistake yeah
they were deceived in the advertising no
doubt about it those people that wanted
the initiative outspend 15 to 1. I
understand that but at one point people
have to say my life is destroyed I don't
care if you're a Democrat or Republican
I can't go shopping there's no stores uh
the taxes are too high I don't my
property values are dipping and this is
all self-inflicted wounds you don't even
need the severity of another country's
culture or crime we know how to do this
we've done it before and now if you
factor in Los Angeles along with the
writer strike and the actor strike so
they're not shooting they're not they're
not shooting movies they're not writing
movies they're not taping shows they're
just shooting up oh yeah they're
shooting up and there's homeless and
there's crime why would anyone live
there but I just don't want them to take
this hellacious attitude and policies to
other places uh Estates like Texas and
Florida who won't tolerate it this is
all self-inflicted this is not hard to
correct and maybe we were about to hit
rock bottom and start fixing things well
it feels like we've hit rock bottom for
the last couple years we're waiting
we're waiting we're waiting still
waiting I know hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else